that in Trump may face a backlash from
gun rights advocates mr. Trump spoke to
conservatives that the conservative
political political action conference
outside Washington Friday the president
said he would rather see trained
teachers with guns instead of sheriffs
deputies who had a chance to stop
alleged Florida shooter Nicholas Cruz
but did not I'd rather have somebody
that loves their students and wants to
protect their students then somebody's
standing outside that doesn't know
anybody and doesn't know the students
and frankly for whatever reason decided
not to go in even though we heard lots
of shots being fired inside the
president said an armed teacher would
have shot the gunman quickly for our the
Governor Rick Scott says he wants to
make it illegal for anyone under 21 or
someone with mental illness to purchase
a gun he also wants an armed law
enforcement officer at every school for
more insight into how some educators are
responding to this push we're joined
from Columbus Ohio by Becky Pringle she
is vice president of the National
Education Association which represents
three million educators across the
country good morning Becky good morning
Alex
can I ask first what is your response to
the president's suggestion that armed
teachers would be better deterrence
against school shooters than perhaps
sheriff's deputies Alex I'm an eighth
grade science teacher the Wonder Years
and I cannot imagine having the
additional responsibility of using a
loaded gun to protect my children that's
not what our students are asking for
it's not what educators all over this
country are asking for that is not what
we need to protect our children Becky
what are you specifically hearing from
teachers on these proposals well you
know what I'm so proud of our teachers
Anthony they aren't and they're so
creative what they have responded with
is a movement they're saying arm me with
counselors army with social workers to
help me address the growing needs that
our students are bringing with them into
the classroom they're saying are me with
tools and resources so that I have the
opportunity to attend to the individual
needs of students that's what they want
to be armed with not guns Becky the
president was also critical of the armed
deputy at Stoneman Douglas High School
he said a security guard doesn't know
the children and doesn't love the
children in making his call to armed
teachers your organization also
represents school security guards what's
been the reaction there we do but you
know it's very easy to criticize and
blame when you're not in that
environment you know I listen to a
teacher from parkland Ashley Kurth talk
about guarding 65 students that day and
she was trying to imagine what it would
be like with hundreds of students as
they were that day running at her and
her having that additional
responsibility to have a loaded weapon
in her classroom that's not what she's
asking for it's not what the students
are asking for they're asking for
changes to our gun laws so that no one
has the ability to have military-grade
assault weapons that are designed for
one purpose to kill as many people as
possible in a short period of time
that is the issue at stake and that's
what our students are asking us to do so
Becky what do you think of governor
Scott's proposal in Florida to put to
put a law enforcement officer in every
public school this is what our our
educators are asking they're asking for
each community school community our
parents our students law enforcement our
administrators to come together and to
come up with solutions that work for
them they want to listen to their
students and to the educators or who are
with them and figure out how they're
going to prepare how they're going to
protect them we need to listen to those
who are closest to our students and do
what's best to protect them Becky what
kind of effect is this conversation
around teachers and their
responsibilities with guns are without
in the
classroom what effect is that having on
the recruitment of young teachers to the
field of education that's a really good
question Alex we certainly have had
challenges to encouraging our young
people to go into education we know that
they don't go into education for the big
bucks or the shiny apples they go into
the education because they love the
students and they want to be there for
their students - in my case open up the
wonders of science they're not going
there because they are going to have
that extra responsibility of protecting
them with a loaded gun and so not only
are we worried about attracting new
teachers to the profession but we're
also worried about retaining those who
are in the profession we're already
hearing not only from teachers but from
school secretaries and other support
staff in our schools that this is not
the kind of environment they want to
work in and anytime someone's proposing
more guns that is not the solution we do
not want to turn our schools into
prisons and our teachers as armed guards
and our students as prisoners that is
not the learning environment we need for
our students
Becky Pringle with the National
Education Association thanks for your
time